then former formula one boss bernie
ecclestone has indicated a not guilty
plea to a charge of fraud at westminster
magistrates court he's accused of
failing to declare 400 million pounds of
overseas assets i'm now joined by skies
aisha zahid who's outside westminster
magistrate's caught for us and i sure it
was a very brief appearance tell us more
about what happened in court
well bernie ecclestone arrived here at
westminster magistrates corps just after
half past nine this morning the hearing
began just after ten o'clock it lasted
around five to ten minutes uh bernie
ecclestone was dressed in a dark blue
suit he appeared in the open dock and
that was allowed because of hearing
issues
that's why the magistrate allowed it now
the former formula one boss is facing
one charge of fraud by false
representation pertaining to dates
between july 2013 and october 2016. it's
allegedly failed to declare over
million dollars of oversea assets to
government and according to the charge
sheet he allegedly claimed
he established a single trust fund in
favor of his daughters it's also alleged
that he said he wasn't a beneficiary of
any other trust fund in or outside the
uk and it's also alleged that he made
the representation to make a game namely
not stated for himself now this charge
was authorized by the crown prosecution
service following an investigation by
her majesty's revenue and custom
that investigation has been described as
being complex and worldwide now
ecclestone
indicated a not guilty plea to this
meaning that the mata has been passed on
to southwark crown court where he will
be appearing for the next hearing on the
19th of september and until then bernie
ecclestone has been granted
unconditional bail